rafael used to walk down this road every
day
now it suddenly just ends
during july's disastrous floods a nearby
gravel pit ran full of water
streets were washed out
everything was ripped away
down there are the houses that used to
be over there
there were five houses next to that
brown house over there
here's the front door of a house that's
no longer standing
this election everything is different in
blessing and its electoral district
even practical matters have been turned
upside down
many people had to leave their houses
that's a problem because in germany
voting documents are sent by mail to a
home address
raphael's neighbor farina bachus is
having her mail forwarded to a friend
she hopes that way her election
documents will reach her
it's such a bureaucratic thing if you
don't get them it's not so easy to get
them sent a second time
something else is unusual on the
district's streets there are no election
placards this year the political parties
have agreed not to politicize the
suffering of flood victims people like
rafael have other problems right now
but still the questions he's asking are
extremely political
america you realize that climate change
doesn't only happen somewhere else
anymore it happens right here and that's
no surprise
germany bears a lot of responsibility
regarding climate change with things
like coal mining
at some point its effects were going to
be felt here
many people here wish that the
government had been more proactive it
could have done more to combat climate
change or at least given people more
protection against the effects raphael
and verena agree that change is needed
if we don't all make a change then
nothing will change
i don't say that to absolve politicians
because they have more opportunities to
affect change in different ways
[Music]
maybe what's happening here now is that
this close to an election we're waking
up and saying from now on things have to
be different
foreign before i either didn't vote at
all or i just voted for someone from one
of the really small parties
but i'm going to think more about it
this time
i'm going to look at what the political
parties are saying and planning in terms
of climate change
but for now life must go on
rafael's apartment is on the second
floor
it was largely spared from the flooding
but now his landlord wants to move in
here
he has to find a new home
his plan is to live in a converted
minivan for the time being
also then when i get this van it'll be a
little home with everything i need
i'll have my clothes and everything
a place to cook and to sleep
i'll always have my home with me
so i
after the election he plans to take the
van to southern europe far away from his
former home in blessing and from german
politics